it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week there's a sneaky thieving
bandit on the loose to be a successful
thief you have to be smooth cunning and
quick to escape unscathed work on
infiltration theft and escape as Garrett
enters the Barons manner grabs the goods
and leaves without a trace grab the
shinies February 25th
this week there's a war going on right
in our own backyard it's plants vs
zombies garden warfare coming out on the
xbox 360 and Xbox one the third person
shooter and tower defense video game
offers co-op along with competitive
multiplayer modes where players can
control the zombies as well as plants so
you can pick if you'd rather have your
zombie butt cracks showing or let the
whole plant just hang out sexy the
battle begins februari 25 also this week
professor layton finally gets his puzzle
solving but to north america and
professor layton and the azran legacy
solve the mystery of the living mummy by
making stuff out of matches moving a
ball into various holes and splitting
milk evenly between three jars to
somehow gather clues and save the day
don't don't get all over the table what
are you doing enjoy the last game or
professor layton is the protagonist
februari 28 yep that's right from now on
it's just you and Luke professor look
listen to my puzzle return to the
creepiest town inhabited by super
violent villagers in HD this week with
resident evil for coming back on PC
remember all the good times you and
Kennedy shared on gamecube ps2 and wii
well now you can relive them on the PC
and shut out all those bad memories of
the original PC port that didn't even
support a mouse or controllers it will
shock you how much it never happened
grab Ashley and GTFO februari 28
and finally he get to make a deal with
death in an effort to defeat Satan in
castlevania lords of shadow 2 what are
you so afraid of it's only Satan follow
the bats februari 25th for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week